foreign
welcome to this new video by simply
learn chat GPT has been helping in
various Fields like customer support
virtual assistant education content
generation language translation research
and information retribal personal
productivity entertainment and more now
talking about content creation then chat
Jeopardy can prove a valuable tool in
idea generation writing enhancement
research and fact checking SEO
optimization and social media content
the power of AI has been overcoming
these days if you are looking to be an
AI engineer and create your own chat GPT
then have a look at the Masters in
artificial intelligence program by
simply learn created in partnership with
IBM it introduces students to a blended
learning and prepares them to be a
specialist in AI in data science you
will gain expertise in tools like numpy
pandas sci-fi Apache spark Keras
tensorflow python R and Scala the
another best part about this course is
that you will get a discount by applying
a discount coupon code ytb E15 so hurry
up and enroll the course now find the
course Link in the description box so
without any further Ado let's begin
chat GPT can assist you with content SEO
or search engine optimization in
following ways number one is keyword
research chat GPT can help you to
identify the relevant keywords and key
phrases that are commonly used in your
industry or required for your topic by
discussing your content with chat gbd
you can uncover valuable keywords to
optimize your content for search engines
so let's find some keywords to create
content on shoes we will create a blog
on shoes so let's add query to chat GPT
so here we got few suggestions we can
pick any of them if needed you can check
these keywords in any keyword research
tool to check their search volumes if
you require so let's choose this keyword
let's write a blog using chat GPT in 500
words on this keyword
next we have is content optimization
chat GPT can provide insights on how to
optimize content for better search
engine rankings it can suggest where to
include keywords naturally within your
content recommends heading structure and
advice on appropriate keyword density so
to the above created blog let's find the
optimization
so here we saw the number of
optimizations suggested by chat GPT for
our content the next we have is meta
tags and descriptions chat GPT can help
you to generate compelling meta tags and
descriptions that accurately represent
your content these elements are
important for search engines to
understand the topic of your content and
display relevant information in search
results so let's ask chat gbd to write a
creative meta descriptions meta title
and meta tags for this block
if needed we can rephrase these meta
descriptions and titles as per our
requirement by providing another query
the next trick to master SEO content
with chat gpts content length and
quality
Jag GPT can guide you on the ideal
length of your content based on the
search engine algorithms and user
preferences it can help you to ensure
that your content is of high quality
engaging and informative which can
positively infect on your SEO ranking so
let's understand what can be the ideal
length of this shoe blog
as we have already written a 500 Words
length of block let's change it to
another one suggested by chat gbt
interlinking and site structure chat GPT
can provide suggestions on how to
structure your content and incorporate
interlinks effectively interlinking
helps search engines to navigate your
website and understand the relationship
between different pages boosting your
overall SEO so let's get few of the link
recommendations for our blogs on shoes
the next one we have is user intent and
readability chat GPT can assist in
understanding user intent and optimizing
your content accordingly by discussing
potential user queries and preferences
you can create content that aligns with
what users are looking for enhancing its
relevance and readability so let's check
out if the readability of the given
block or block created by chat GPT is
good or not
you can also test some other content
with chat GPT to check whether its
readability is good or not while child
GPT can provide a valuable guidance it's
important to remember that SEO is a
complex field and requires a holistic
approach it's advisable to combine chat
GPT suggestions with best practices
industry knowledge and ongoing SEO
strategies to achieve optimal results
before we end this topic here what our
Learners say about our courses finishing
the course led to personal recognition
and
door for even more artificial
intelligence projects and it came with a
significant pay raise money ahead
no Steve Jobs once said the only way to
do something great is to love what you
do and if you haven't found it yet keep
looking never settle
so after taking the course from Simply
learn
I discovered my passion hi my name is
D'Angelo and I reside in Ridgefield
Washington I completed simply learns
artificial intelligence master's program
for as long as I can remember I've been
fascinated by it and interested in
Cutting Edge technology even though I
was confident in my field I was eager to
broaden my knowledge and meet the
evolving need for my employer and others
like them after much research I decided
to use simply learn to enhance my
knowledge simply learns flexible
learning strategy allowed me to balance
out school with a full-time job and
Route applications I'm glad I stuck with
it because finishing the course led to
personal recognition and opened the door
for even more artificial intelligence
projects and it came with a significant
pay raise money to add by not settling I
could find the job that I genuinely
enjoy doing in addition I've been able
to put my acquired knowledge to Great
use as a volunteer for the first Global
organization that helps kids through
constructive machines and robots the
experience has been very enjoyable and
very rewarding if you want to succeed in
Corporate America you have to constantly
learn new skills and sharpen the ones
that you already have
when I hear people talking about one of
their learning skills I mean snow
brainer simply like
I hope to be a CEO of my own software
company one day also I love sharing what
I've learned with others AI is such a
fascinating area of study and practice I
believe more people should be trained to
work in this field because it's one of
several new emerging Technologies
leading the charge in the fourth
industrial industry
if you're driven to accomplish something
don't be afraid to die right here
getting started is just half the battle
and once you do you'll be glad you did
you can do anything you set your mind to
so never stop dreaming and never stop
achieving remember there's always room
for growth don't see yourself any less
than what you see other people be
capable of because if they can do it
I can do it
I know you can do it so here we end this
topic if you like this video consider
subscribing to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply learn thanks for watching this
video
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
foreign